my name is Gocha converse sky i work as
a kernel developer here at war on
research and i'm gonna give the
traditional talk on time series
processing time series is not a new
object in in Wolfram languages has been
around for a while and my talk is in no
way I would be not able even if I rush
to prefer to cover everything so this is
a subjective selection on the topics
with focus on the new functionality so
the plan is a short introduction and as
you see I start with zero on my
enumeration to kind of keep in mind that
when we talk about serial data in
Mathematica automatically we start
enumerate in at zero so i will talk
about the new functionality of direct
arithmetic and function application and
about the video processing functions for
time series then our redesign moving
mouse so the changes and augmentation to
the moving map and then about the
proliferation of time series that we see
throughout our from language so we have
three types of serial data in Wolfram
language these are the time series which
is probably the most known event series
in temporal data and temporal data is
existing in Mathematica since version 9
so that's the oldest object so um time
series the basic assumption about time
series is the observations that we what
we have are in the continuous in the
continuous-time and there is only one
path allowed to be stored in the time
series and it could be univariate or the
multivariate but the dimensional must be
consistent by default the values between
the timestamps are being interpolated
this method of interpolation how we want
to fill them in can be set and by
default this is in a linear
interpolation so a few examples that I
have here our interests playing on the
on the precision in a way so I have can
define the simple time series of random
real so that's the values and then
the the time starts at zero so this is
the way to extract the path for people
who is completely new to time series and
then the question of you know
interpolation between the times x is
what do you get if you ask you know TS
real of one half right so our time
stamps are integers here 0 1 2 and so on
and if you what is what do we get when
we ask for the for the value in between
the given time stamps and in this case
this is there in your interpolation so
we get the real value another example
I'm going to have the real integer
values and integer timestamps so you can
see how the path looks like and in this
case when we ask for the value in
between the timestamps we get an integer
because of the of the nature of the of
the time series but we can also have the
integer values and the real time stamps
and then if we ask for the value at in
between those time stamps we're gonna
get machine precision because there were
time stamps were in the machine
precision and if those are taken into
the calculation of the value in between
the times x then this Precision's cannot
carry over I mentioned that the the
method of interpolation between the time
stamps can be set and this can be done
if we we can kind of redefine the time
series so define time series on the
existing time series and said they're a
sampling method and so this is what I'm
doing in defining T is free so I take
the the previous time series and I'm
redefining with their something method
of interpolation where the interpolation
order is 0 so now when you look at the
paths they are absolutely the same
because I didn't do anything to the
values that are the observations they
only change the behavior in between the
observations and in this way when you
look at what what we get at the one half
is the value being held from the left so
it's 10 the other way to change this
behavior in between the times x is 2 for
example set a constant and i have here
actually a symbol a
and you can see that i did it i change
this the t is real with this sampling
method and the path didn't change but of
course when we ask what is the value in
between the timestamps it's going to be
a symbol and also i would like to point
out when you look at this small outputs
here they have small plots in each
output and the small plots are going to
kind of refer to what we can what we can
get when we plot this time series so in
this case we see that there is there is
a linear interpolation here in this case
i change the interpolation order to zero
so our plot looks you know partially
flood in between the timestamps and here
in this output which is get nothing
because we don't know what the value of
AES is just a symbol so it doesn't know
what to give us as a preview of this
behavior even serious it's much faster
and and you know cleaner case basically
we assume that we are having
discrete-time observations and nothing
happens in between the timestamps and
this kind of bitter set so you know like
if you want to have a for example the
note observations of you know number of
deaths that's really not what we would
like to interpolate between the
timestamps so morbid example what so if
you ask for the value in between the
timestamps it's missing and that's all
what we can do now temporal data it's a
more general structure and in a way it
behaves similarly to time series and can
be fought as a generalization of that or
time series is a special case of
temporal data and we assume again the
continuous-time observations but in this
case we allow more than one path so we
can have multiple paths but we need to
have a consistent dimensionality through
that for the puffs and this is for the
slice distribution I'll show example for
that in a moment that by default we have
interpolation between between x terms
again this method can be set and here by
default the
zero order of interpolation so the value
is called from the left so example of
some temporal data this is a to puff
temporal data one path has four
observations that there is free we can
create temporal data from existing time
series which the creatures drop time
series temporal data around the list of
time series and we just created a new
object and each time series becomes a
new path a single path in the inner
temporal data and now the difference
between the time series temporal data is
that for the value in you know for the
it's not necessarily just in between the
times on both any value or the given
time it's going to give us a data
distribution because this is a design to
study the slice distribution so we
assume really that we have maybe lots of
paths and we would like to know what are
the properties of the sliced
distribution an example application is
where these temporal data objects
actually first came to be is with the
simulation of random processes so what I
have here it's a simulation of a vineri
process in its from 0 to 1 in steps of
100 and I simulate thousand puffs and
this is the storage for for such
simulations a temporal data and at the
point 3 i'm going to have a data
distribution and we can for example plot
the cdf of this distribution we can also
sample from this data distribution so
this is the slice and the this is the
slice distribution that's the story
tickle slice and we can compare the
histogram with the PDF of the
theoretical distribution slice
distribution
so the last part of the introduction is
a little bit on the on the
technicalities of it but we have for
time series and temporal data event
series we have options and we have
properties okay so options can be
retrieved by just asking options in the
time series and you see that most of
these options refer to the dates so
there will be a mostly calendar options
to find the properties of a time series
we really need to define first valid
time series object and then just ask for
properties and so we have 14 properties
prefer two times puffs and values
options for the event series are very
similar to those of the time series
however there's one option missing in
the event series which is there a
sampling method because we don't have
the sampling set for event series as I
said properties also almost the same as
for the time series the only thing that
it's missing is the puff function
because we don't have that a sampling
method so we cannot really define the
path function we don't know what happens
in between the timestamps now for the
temporal data options are identical to
the loops of time series and then when
you look at the properties we have many
more 27 because we have multipath
properties so it's not that i'm going to
ask just for the for the path but i may
ask for all the paths just not further
just first both times i may ask for the
times for all the possible paths that
are stored in the the temporal data okay
so moving past the introduction we're
going to work with the weather union I
mean for those who went to my talk
yesterday this is a the commented code
is the is the call exactly how to obtain
this time series i just have it as a
shortcut here that this time series are
already defined so what we have here is
the temperature so que si mi is
basically a weather station here in
champaign so this is for the September
and say oh that we want to find the
maximum temperature for this period so
with the direct you know our arithmetic
and direct
function application we can just apply
maximum to the time series and get the
result okay and what we can see from
this that our original time series
contains some missing information so the
weather station would say that yes that
would be a time stamp that I would
record some you know data are
temperature data but there was no record
for that time so I have a missing you
know information so we can fix those
because we have an option which is
missing data method and we can say okay
let's fill them you know with
interpolation and when you look at the
plot you see that they are small holes I
don't know this is visible out here but
you see that there are some small
missing things right some little pieces
so it makes sense to maybe use the
interpolation you know interpolation to
feel the main and maybe it's not going
to change much in the in a big scope of
things so one possibility it's to run
the you know interpolating function okay
we got something and we have an error
message okay but in the fact you know
don't be afraid of this because this
message basically says that
extrapolation was used and it basically
means that one of the edge edge values
was the missing value so what happened
is that either the first or the last
value probably was missing and
interpolation had to go outside of the
domain and use that and also the input
value that you see here which is 38 36 8
and so on this is absolute time because
underneath we're gonna use the absolute
time I mean for the time being we are
using the absolute time to to deal with
the timestamps so when I check this is T
is 1 is the is the first the original
time series that indeed see that the
first value was the missing value okay
but now when I apply the maximum to the
kind of fixed time series 30 is too I
got the number you know so the clean-cut
number okay but this is still not not
really I'm not really happy with this I
would like to know what units it is
because if i look at the 32.8 and you
tell me the temperature is 32.9 socio
fahrenheit because that changes the
picture completely
so we know from the we know from the
weather data that I used that the
temperature output it's in Celsius so
what we can do here is to wrap the
values from the time series into the
quantity array at the degrees Celsius
and then use the dates from the time
series to create a new one and then
thank you I don't know how the Polish
spells and English it's just completely
us off so yes thank you but anyway we
got nicely the 32.8 tells you so we had
a nice warm September for those people
who do not operate in Celsius were are
already prone to typos in this like me
we can actually convert so out of
Fahrenheit so what I'm applying directly
here is just a unit converter on the
whole time series two degrees Fahrenheit
and then I can plot this and so now
quote is filled it has that it has the
label of the of the degrees and then we
can if you want we can find the maximum
temperature in the degrees of Fahrenheit
so okay second example for for this type
of manipulation is I have a financial
time series in u.s. dollars and
attending the in the comments is the is
the way to get this you know data this
is a starbucks stock prices that I wrap
already in the quantity so we have
dollars so now what I would like to do
it is no maybe how much this is in euro
if i apply you need to convert to euro
what it's going to do it's going to pull
the current you know conversion rate so
fine we're not fine yeah but i am owned
on the table so
should be fine let's hope that it's
gonna you know fetches the current
conversion rate eventually okay so
assuming this works Oh see ya know so
the point is my point is that if i use
unit convert directly like you see here
you need convert TS time series and euro
what it's going to do it's going to try
to connect to the server pull the
current at this moment it says whatever
the information we have on the server
conversion rate and then apply it to the
whole time series and well it is
somewhat useful if you have for example
a current value and you want to convert
that but what I would like to point out
that i don't i think that important for
this type of analysis is to actually
pull the historical conversion rate so
this is again commented out called how
you can get the time series that i have
for the rates this is fluval from alpha
coal and can define the rights and you
can see that my rates are the euros per
US dollar and then what i can do is to
directly multiply the rates times my
original prices to get the conversion
okay and i cannot plot everything but i
can plot this so I'll ignore the build
legends then because it's not so that
was maybe better to commend ourselves so
so this is going to be directly
multiplying two time series and then it
also see that our time stamps resolved
to the to the to the right way so I have
one more example here about the
Directorate magic over the time series
and it's a very simple example of
addition because I would like to just
mention how the time stamps are being
resolved when we have misaligned time
series so here I have two time series
and then I do the number line plot a
kind of see where the time stamps for
each of the time series happen and you
see that some of them are in common some
of them are not and then if i define the
sum so i can just add this one plus
tears to you can see on the plot that i
have the the sum it's kind of the
duration of the sometimes risks it sits
in between the durations of all the bow
of time series and so basically what
what happens is that we first find the
common duration of the of the time
series and in this case it's this
interval between one and three and a
half and then we look into this duration
and find the union of the of the of the
timestamps and then on this union of the
timestamps we're going to do the
audition because we can interpolate and
so this trick works only when we have
both time series it's not going to work
the same way for event series because we
cannot interpolate in between the
existing timestamps so that's going to
be the the times
okay a little bit on the processing
function so we have a the whole list of
functions which kind of start with time
series and something and they are
specific specifically designed to work
with the time series I'll have example
here for the support i'm serious window
because it does do because it it you
know it is something with weather and
i'd like to work with weather but
basically we had a hurricane Matthew
that that passed through you know
caribbean three weeks ago and i looked
up or NOAA boy on the caribbean sea and
this boy registers there certain things
like temperature or wings and so on so
you can actually go to the website or no
and you can extract this data and what I
did was to get the text file and then do
some processing I could after the talk
explain if anybody is interested and
created a time series and this is for 45
days and so when I plot this it's it has
to it has kind of two components is to
sustain swings and gas and when I look
at this it kind of looks man okay and I
know when the idenna know when the
hurricane happened so what I can do is
to kind of narrow myself zoom into the
window of time when it actually happens
so I'm going to start at the 29th of
September automatic goes to the end of
the of the of the time series and then
when I look at this I kind of see the
interesting thing that happened
basically the I went over the boy okay
so you see the speed when out then the
speed went down so we have the eye and I
see something interesting going on
convert to the miles per hour and also
instead of converting the whole time
series we have useful thing in
visualizations that you can just set the
target units in the visualization
function and then just plot the time
series with the new units for the photo
in the visualization okay one remark on
the on the time series map even though
we have a direct
you know function application on the
time series doesn't make the time series
mob being obsolete because when we own
this situation we have we have a
three-dimensional you know path here and
if I apply just maximum directly to my
time series and I just got the one
single number which is maximum of all
the components but if I would like to
find the marks for each value then I
would exactly go the time series map so
this function is still you know useful
for it for the especially for the vector
valued time series and this is the list
of remaining other you know processing
functions that I will not talk about not
going to talk about the moving map so
moving map can be used to do the
smoothing and finning so I have a gun
this is the same data the the window
data for the hurricane Matthew wins as
you recall I had two dimensions for the
sustained wind and the gusts I would
like to just work with one of them so
I'm going to take the first puff
component and there's going to be just a
sustained winds here so 12 hours moving
mean that means using the moving map
with mean on the wind which is my time
serious and then specify the 12-hour
window and by default that the windows
are placed on the on the right so the
plot says kind of shows us exactly how
this looks like after smoothing but i
would like to also fill my time series
so in this way two fingers i'm going to
specify that the placement of my windows
happens every six hours so i'm still 12
our windows but i'm going to place them
only every six hours and when you
compare now the path lengths for each of
the time series originals moved and fins
you see that we change dramatically when
we placed windows every six hours versus
the previous result however you see
there is little difference in the plot
between the smoothing and feeling so
we're going to save ourselves you know
if we we have control over the the
windows you know how how much windows
how many windows we would really want to
want to want to place and a new thing
also is that we can now specify the
positions of the windows
precision so say I would like to specify
them every six hours but i want to start
@midnight so this is my position spec
and here i have to to moving moms
because i would like to place my windows
on the left or on the right just for
just to kind of show you straight that
and then comparing the first dates you
see that we started different different
times and the first date is the actual
first observation in a time series the
second is the the simple you know moving
map application when we just had the
feeling ever you know every six hours
but then the third and the fourth one
they will have on the full hour because
we wanted to start @midnight so then we
go every six hours from midnight so
that's going to be here always on the
full hour and here's just a timeline of
the of the stumps so you can see how
they are aligning the pending of our
specification of the older windows okay
time series everywhere i just want to
show that we have time series happening
throughout the Wolfram language i'm sure
i'm not going to get all the other
examples around but some of them so one
of this displaces where we can encounter
time series is data being so i have a
data been defined it should be empty it
is i can send some counts that I call
observations to the date have been you
can see that they are actually the
counter it's going on the on the on the
data bin icon so I went to 20 and if i
apply time series to the beam it's going
to return all the possible time series
that i have in this data beam but i can
extract the exact time series that i
want which is called observations and we
can we can plot the observations know
what happened started again
ah the break in the network okay and
then I'm just going to clean the bee I
am running out of time but i would like
to mention that that there is also audio
properties so when we have the example
of some audio the local measurements for
audio or will often return to time
series we get some sampling and want to
return the time series and we can easily
then just get the summaries on the on
the time series what I find interesting
is to generate a time series and since I
cannot really get the sound out of here
sorry for some reason this is upload a
ball from the possible so maybe just for
later we want to upload download and the
other the other example is to vote from
knowledge base so we get this through
the entity lots of entities now will
give us the time serious so this is the
distance from air to son we got the time
series right now I can we can get the
distance right now we can convert this
to the astronomical unit we can plot our
time series we can find the mean and the
standard deviation of the distance this
is another example of the direct
arithmetic for the time series find the
force of attraction that the sound
exerted on the earth it returns again
the time series because the distance was
time series and then we can convert the
mean of the spores into the mutants and
one more thing here is that when we have
for example population of the country
and we have dated population it's going
to give us a time series we can extract
the first value for example we can plot
you can see that the population is kind
of going not going what I have here is
just a linear model fit to the log of
values and also using the fine feed by
the sigmoid feed the sigmoid function
just to kind of see what happens and we
see that moving out the population it's
time during you know out and so
since i'm close to the time and it's
close to the talk i'm going to thank you
and i wanted to advertise the related
talks but i think unless you have a time
machine you won't be able to actually
attend because they already happened but
i think that for some that note books
are available and for other you my talk
to the speaker so if there are any
questions then
[Applause]